TODAY, WE INTRODUCE YOU TO THE
ATMOSPHERE BARKOV AND HIS
BONDN THE SECOND MINUTE OF
THE OPENING FRAME.
BACKSTROM  ONE-ON-ONE OPPORTUNI
HERE.
RIPPED UPSTAIRS.
HUBERDEAU MAKES IT 1-0
CATCHING MET UP
LOST POSSESSION.
ANOTHER OKS AROUNDGREAT SAVE BY
GOALTENDING THERE FOR
BOBROVSKY.
A GAME SAVER.
SCREEN IN FRONT
OF THE NET GAME APIECE. TIED
HUBERDEAU GOES BEHIND THE BACK.
BARKOV UNCORKED ONE. SAMSONOV.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN GOING OUT FOR
THE POST.
HUBERDEAU.
CENTERING PASS.
ANTHONY MANTHA.
HE WILL GET THE PRIMARY ASSIST.
HE HAS HAD A HECK OF
TODAY.
BACKSTROM.
AT THE SET PIECE.
STOPPED BY BOBROVSKY.
REBOUND WAS
IT IS DOWN IN THE BUTTERFLY.
HE LOSES HIS S S VAN RIEMSDYK. E
ALMOST HOOKED UP WITH GIROUX.
A CENTERING PASS.
OVECHKIN TAKES IT ON THE RUN.
OVECHKIN A STOP WITH THE RIGHT
HE BEATS
CARLSON.
BULL'S-EYERVARY ON REINHART.
LONG-RANGE RIGHT INTO THE NET
THIS IS GOING TO DO IN THE LORD
OF PANTHERS.
GO.
HECK OF A BALL GAME TODAY.
THEY HAVE SHUT DOWN FOR THE
MOST PART  -- THE BARKOV TRI